[Musik]
man weiß nie wieder sehen jetzt dass
jahr verläuft es ist eigentlich wieder
alles so was kommt nach der
morgendlichen variante was es danach
nach impfungen haben wir durchbruch und
hatten beide kone und vor dem
hintergrund ist es so dass wir
auch angst haben was ich finde dass es
endlich mal bundeseinheitlich wird nicht
dass jedes bundesland wieder seine
sachen nach ich bin sowieso der
befürworter dass die ganze sache offen
gemacht wird wie in schweden das muss
einmal durch gesorgt sein und dann ist
gut sie sind geimpft also wir gehen auch
schon ein bisschen lockerer mit um im
moment wie zu anfang wo man nicht wusste
was da auf einen zukommen verstecken tue
ich mich nicht deswegen
stimmen auf den straßen der hansestadt
hamburg an dem tag da die politik
darüber berät wie sie mit dieser so
ansteckende variante namens omikron
umgehen soll und damit herzlich
willkommen zu diesem zdf spezial erst
kurz vor weihnachten hatten sich bund
und länder zuletzt zusammen geschaltet
unter anderem kontakt beschränkungen
auch für geimpfte beschlossen und schon
damals war absehbar dass dies nicht
reichen würde und genau so ist es
gekommen der vierten folgt fast nahtlos
die omikron welle wohl spätestens
nächste woche wird die variante ja
überall im lande die dominierende sein
mit dem ziel sie in schach zu halten
haben bundeskanzler scholz und die 16
ministerpräsidenten und präsidentinnen
heute folgendes beschlossen
gepostete frisch geimpfte und jungs
genesene sind von einer quarantäne
ausgenommen wer kontakt mit einer
infizierten hatte muss künftig nur noch
für zehn tage in quarantäne
nach sieben tagen kann man sich frei
testen in der gastronomie gilt ab dem 15
januar die sogenannte zweig plus
regelung also nur geimpfte und genesene
mit negativ test oder booster impfung
kommen rein fürs einkaufen für bus und
bahn fahren empfehlen bund und länder
heute dringend eine fb2 maske zu tragen
außerdem wird dazu aufgerufen noch mehr
im home office zu arbeiten
die aktuellen kontakt beschränkungen die
bleiben in kraft
und dazu begrüße ich den
ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen und vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
der wüste
schönen guten abend sie haben mir heute
beschlüsse gefasst die er auf ja
vermutungen beruhenden auf verlässlichen
daten zur infektions lage ist das nicht
ein bisschen corona politik im nebel
flug
wenn wir die entwicklung den letzten
tagen sehen die sind erstmals wieder
über der 300er marke wir haben einen
eher faktor der in nahezu allen
bundesländern über 1 ist wenn wir ins
nachbarland in die nachbarländer schauen
nach dänemark die niederlande nach
frankreich oder noch spanien die sehr
gut voran beim impfen dann haben wir
durchaus eine gute grundlage für das was
uns in den nächsten tagen erwartet und
deswegen konnten wir heute auch zusammen
kommen und beschlüsse fassen und obwohl
uns das schlimmes erwartet sieht man in
den heutigen beschlüssen eigentlich
wenig neues zweig plus in der
gastronomie sticht da noch heraus aber
eben keine weiteren kontakt
beschränkungen bars kneipen bleiben
weiter offen ist auch mikron wirklich so
zu besiegen darüber haben wir heute auch
diskutiert der expertenrat hat uns
aufgefordert uns so aufzustellen dass
wir sehr schnell entscheidungen treffen
können darüber gab es auch nicht in
jedem einzelnen detail einigkeit
quarantäne regeln war noch ein großes
thema und haben natürlich die
einschränkungen die maßnahmen der
letzten sitzungen bekräftigt die weiter
fortbestehen und natürlich neue im chile
wie wir uns setzen die wichtig sind dass
boostern ist der beste schutz ich hätte
mir auch gewünscht dass wir bei der
impfpflicht jetzt schon etwas weiter
gekommen wäre ein konkreter mindestens
ein zeitplan
hätten aber wir kommen eben auch im
januar noch einmal zusammen neu sind
auch verkürzte quarantänevorschriften
auch für betroffene beschäftigte in
krankenhäusern
haben sie persönlich ein gutes gefühl
dabei immerhin geht es ja hier um wohl
mehr abele gruppen die unbedingt vor
ansteckung geschützt werden müssen das
oberste prinzip bei quarantäne regeln
muss sein infektionen zu unterbinden
dafür gibt es quarantäne regeln wir
haben das jetzt neu bewerten lassen rein
fachlich und sind dem gefolgt weil wir
auf der anderen seite natürlich
kritische infrastruktur insbesondere das
gesundheitssystem aufrecht erhalten
müssen wenn sehr viele menschen
infiziert sind heißt das gleichzeitig
auch viele kontaktpersonen müssen in
quarantäne und gerade wer kontakt hat zu
wohlhabenden personen
das war besonders wichtig dass wir da
sicherheit dass ihr schutz garantieren
diese personen können sich nur freitags
klassen mit einem pcr test nicht mit
einem normalen test und wenn sie zwei
tage ohne symptome sind ich glaube das
ist dann am ende ein vertretbarer schutz
in der abwägung zwischen maximaler
sicherheit möglichst maximaler
sicherheit und aufrechterhaltung der
funktionsfähigkeit insbesondere des
gesundheitssystems sagte der
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen danke für das
gespräch herr willst dann geh in der
kinder
umgesetzt werden müssen die beschlüsse
jetzt vor allem auf kommunaler ebene
stefan mohrdieck ist landrat des kreises
dithmarschen in schleswig holstein haben
sich dann ihre erwartungen an die
heutige bund länder runde erfüllt
ja guten erstmal kinder ja wir sind
eigentlich ganz froh die gaststätten
aufzuhalten das sicherlich eine richtige
maßnahme wir sind froh dass das
funktioniert die regeln dafür sind
aufgestellt worden wir müssen natürlich
im auge behalten ob das noch schärfer
wird oder ob das reicht und das wird ja
ohnehin nachgesteuert aber wenn es
schärfer wird ist sie wieder zu
befürchten dass sich dinge auch in das
private umfeld verlagern und dann
weniger kontrolliert werden können dass
es so eine befürchtung dabei aber alles
in allem muss man sagen es ist
sicherlich richtig dann auch hier die
regeln so festzulegen dass man diese
heutigen regeln so anwendet auch durch
eine tanzveranstaltung am vierten advent
liegt der die inzidenz bei ihnen im
landkreis aktuell bei über 800 werden
denn jetzt die verkürzten quarantäne
fristen die heute beschlossen worden
sind die personalsituation etwa im
medizinischen bereiche entspannen
ja das haben wir ganz aktuell heute
schon umgesetzt und haben dadurch auch
deutlich personal wieder gewonnen das
waren mittlerweile bis zu 200 personen
in unserem klinikum ausgefallen durch
die quarantänemaßnahmen und durch die
rücknahme der zeiten ja haben wir 75
personen zurück gewinnen können das ist
wichtig bald das ist das größere problem
mittlerweile in der klinik weniger die
tatsächlich infizierten und kranken die
dort aufschlagen
können sich die menschen bei ihnen im
landkreis dennoch überzeugen von diesem
ständigen wechsel von verschärfungen
lockerungen und neuen verschärfungen mit
der bitte um eine kurze antwort
das ist das größte problem mittlerweile
dass die leute das nicht mehr verstehen
nicht mehr hinterherkommen wie man so
schön sagt diese maßnahmen auch nicht
immer plausibel sind und darum muss es
eigentlich auch gehen bei diesen neuen
maßnahmen sie müssen klar und deutlich
sein in diesen gut erklärt sein und dann
werden sie auch akzeptiert und wir haben
weniger probleme hier vor ort sie
umzusetzen der appell aus dem ausland
danke herr mutig für dieses gespräch
danke gerne
ja das neue jahr hat begonnen die
pandemie ist allerdings geblieben mehr
noch sie ist auf dem vormarsch dank
einer variante die deutlich
anstrengender ist als data umfangreicher
getestet und sequenziert wird in
deutschland trotzdem nicht und so
beginnt das neue jahr beinahe wie die
ganze pandemie nämlich in gewisser
ahnungslosigkeit
neues jahr neues glück vorerst wohl eher
vernebelte aussichten auf das
infektionsgeschehen omikron ante portas
oder sind wir längst in der fünften
welle allein aus den zahlen werden wir
zum jahresbeginn nicht schlauer die
neuinfektionen steigen aber das lka
warnt vor unvollständigen daten und
hoher dunkelziffer von zahlen chaos und
vertrauen weg ist die rede zu viele
gesundheitsämter schulen kitas und
betriebe sind noch im ferienmonat
mit sorge geht der blick in
nachbarländer wie frankreich und
dänemark wo die inzidenz neue
höchstwerte erreichen oder nach
großbritannien wo omikron bereits seit
dezember dominiert mit täglich 200.000
19 doch ein blick auf die durchgeführten
tests macht deutlich wie wenig die
infektionszahlen zum vergleich tauben
fünfmal so viele tests in großbritannien
vier mal so viele in frankreich
entsprechend höher ist auch die zahl der
positiven ergebnisse
auch hierzulande dürfte omikron noch im
januar dominieren seit mitte november
verdoppelt sich die zahl der fälle alle
drei bis vier tage bundesweit bestätigt
das lka bislang 62
1974 fälle
absolute zahlen ohne aussagekraft nicht
einmal fünf prozent der positivtests
werden genetisch sequenziert deutschland
zeichnet ein diffuses bild
der omicron anteil liegt zwischen 3,2
prozent in sachsen-anhalt
69,4 in schleswig holstein und 85,5 in
bremen große schwankungen weil
bundesländer unterschiedlich auf die
neue variante testen und ergebnisse
verzögert melden grund zur hoffnung
geben britische studie im vergleich zur
delta variante werden nur 33 prozent der
omicron infizierten bislang
hospitalisiert allerdings könnte die
hohe ansteckungsrate zu engpässen führen
wenn sie befürchtet auch hier 30 prozent
des medizinischen personals durch
erkrankungen oder quarantäne ausfallen
viel stoff für unser gespräch mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister guten abend
herr lauterbach kohl nahm trainer vor
der heutigen runde hatten sie sich ja
immer wieder für nachgeschärfte kontakt
beschränkungen ausgesprochen aber nun
bleibt es bei den bestehenden regeln das
kann sie doch heute nicht zufrieden
stimmen naja es bleibt nicht mal den
bestehenden regeln sondern wir haben
hier nach geschäft im bereich der
gastronomie zweig plus das heißt also
man kann aus in die gastronomie nur
eintreten indem man geimpft ist und hat
zusätzlich einen test oder man ist
gepustet das ist eine deutliche
verbesserung war das war eine wichtige
quelle der infektion ein problembereich
denn man sitzt oft stundenlang in der
gastronomie hat keine maske an und das
ist für nikon natürlich also sehr
gefährlich von daher ist das schon ein
wichtiger schritt der kontakt begrenzung
das heißt beide nach schaffung für
kontakte im privaten raum bis zu zehn
personen bei kämpften halten sie trotz
nikon derzeit nicht für notwendig naja
bei den geimpften muss man bedenken dass
mittlerweile gott sei dank ein großer
teil die booster impfung bekommen hat
und dass die poster kampagne mit vollgas
läuft und ich so setze einfach darauf
dass wir in diesem soja
wettrennen ländern sowie zwischen der
booster impfung auf der einen seite und
der ausbeutung der omicron variante dass
wir da sehr viele mit der booster
impfung noch erreichen bevor die fahrt
zahl und zu stark steigen daher aus sind
die regelungen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
aus meiner sicht ausreichend und beruhen
die beschlüsse von heute ja auf zahlen
die das infektionsgeschehen vor allem
die tatsächliche verbreitung von omikron
nur unzureichend abbilden das haben sie
selbst so gesagt müsste jetzt nicht
dringend mehr getestet und vor allem
sequenziert werden wir sequenzieren in
deutschland mittlerweile viele auch im
vergleich zu anderen europäischen
ländern und wir haben natürlich im
vorfeld dieser beschlüsse haben wir die
tatsächlichen zahlen ab oxidiert also
hochgerechnet und wir haben mittlerweile
ein relativ gutes bild über das
infektionsgeschehen wir wissen zum
beispiel was die zahl der omicron
infizierten sich ungefähr im abstand von
fünfeinhalb tagen verdoppelt und wir
wissen dass die zahl der data
infizierten langsam herunter geht somit
also sind die zahlen ausreichend und gut
wir müssen allerdings erfolgreich sein
um die zahlen abzubremsen und da ist
tatsächlich die impfung und gerade die
booster impfung das wichtigste
instrument und eben die erstimpfung für
die ungeimpften aber damit können die
wenigstens den schweren verlauf und
manchmal den tod anwenden was ist
eigentlich mit der gesetzlichen pflicht
alle 16 bundesländer sind dafür der
kanzler hatte sie für februar
angekündigte wie ernst ist es der
bundesregierung jetzt wirklich damit
naja die bundesregierung wird die
impfpflicht ja nicht beschließen und
also die
ministerpräsidentin ministerpräsidenten
können hier nur ihre eigene position
vortrag sie sind für die impfpflicht für
die allgemeine nebenpflicht das ist auch
der bundeskanzler das bin ich auch aber
wir als regierung und auch die
ministerpräsidenten können dem deutschen
bundestag in einer solchen
gewissensentscheidung keine vorgaben
machen wir können weder also vorgeben
wanders beschlossen werden soll und wie
es beschlossen werden soll wir können
hier nur unsere position als
einzelpersonen mitteilen das haben wir
heute getan die perspektive des
bundesgesundheitsministers danke nach
berlin ich danke ihnen
tja wo bleibt das erhoffte licht am ende
des tunnels wir werden das wohl selbst
anknipsen müssen die politik mit einem
krisen management das mehr als nur auf
sicht fährt die behörden mit optimierter
mit verbesserter datenerfassung und die
wissenschaft die ihren beitrag leisten
aber auch gehör finden muss das war
unser zdf spezial danke für ihr
interesse und hier im programm geht es
weiter mit betis diagnose auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]